[Music]
have you ever noticed how some Disney
couples are just made for each other
but they aren't always in the same
movies thanks to fanfiction we can see
some amazing Disney crossover ships stay
tuned to find out our favorite Disney
OTP hey Disney fans if you are totally
obsessed with all things Disney you
should click Subscribe now let's get
into the 10 Disney crossover couples
everybody ships milo and jane our first
Disney crossover couple is milo from
Atlantis the lost Empire and Jane from
Tarzan these two characters have a lot
in common they are both stars of
seriously underrated Disney movies
they're both smart and love learning and
neither are afraid to go on an adventure
we think this might be one of the cutest
ships ever we know what you're thinking
they are already paired up with other
couples
Jane ends up with Tarzan and Milo ends
up with Keira but we think that Milo and
Jane are a much better ship they can
talk about all their nerdy research
interests together and they can go on
all sorts of fun expeditions Jane needs
someone who can match her intelligence
and keep up in conversation Milo is that
guy she will help him get out of his
shell and she won't think he's crazy
with all his research we aren't the only
ones who think so check out you dropped
your pen on fanfiction.net it's by
flowers and fudge it's an A you studying
so you don't even have to worry about
the story messing with canon in this one
milo has a huge crush on Jane and tries
to win her over
Maleficent and Jafar even villains need
love right Maleficent might be the
evilest villain of all of Disney she was
the sorceress who cursed Aurora and
Sleeping Beauty and she did that all
because she didn't get invited to
Aurora's birth celebration
she she is powerful and she can even
turn into a dragon
then there's Jafar from Aladdin he is
the Royal vizier of the kingdom of
Agrabah and he is a total power-hungry
psycho once he gets ahold of the lamp he
becomes super powerful these two have a
lot in common and it may not be the
healthiest relationship but they are a
perfect match if you want to see a bit
of their relationship check out
fanfiction.net Jafar Maleficent was
written by demons and vampires it's a
funny one shot with a heavy dose of
romance it's all about Jafar wanting to
go public with their relationship but
Maleficent isn't so sure
as far as Disney villain ships go this
is a pretty popular one hey do you think
Maleficent and Jafar from descendants
could end up together heaven make Jay
and mal stepbrother and stepsister witch
villains do you ship together we think
Jafar Maleficent are a match made and
well heaven but someplace Merida and
Rapunzel sometimes people wish Disney
movies had a bit more representation but
thanks to fanfic he can find all sorts
of couples and we love seeing a couple
princesses in love meh Rapunzel is a
pretty common ship in the fanfic world
both Merida and Rapunzel represent the
more modern chapter of Disney Princesses
Merida is the first-ever princess to not
have a love story
sheesh eyes away from tradition and
wants to create her own destiny
descendent of she's uninhibited and a
little bit wild
so is Rapunzel she knows exactly what
she wants and she isn't afraid to go
after it Plus Merida and Rapunzel are
about the same age and they can bond
over their mommy issues there's a great
story on Wattpad by guro a brave and
tangled love is about Merida often
adventures around Europe she meets
Rapunzel and she instantly thinks she's
beautiful
she needs a place to stay and Rapunzel
invites her to stay with her and the
rest is history it's a great love story
and it's got 32 chapters you'll keep
wanting more but luckily there are
several more me Rapunzel stories out
there we can totally get behind this
ship what about you Marie and Oliver fan
fiction isn't just for the human Disney
characters there's something out there
for just about every fandom and we are
kicking it old school for this next ship
remember when Disney made two films
about cats Oliver in company was a 1988
movie about a kitten named Oliver who is
taken in by a pack of dogs in New York
the Aristocats came out in 1970 it was
about some spoiled rich cats who end up
lost outside and meet up with an alley
cat Murray was a kitten from the
Aristocats and she was the cutest all
the fern marie's show up in fan art
every now and then but they have also
made a fan fiction appearance and we are
all here for it go girl
1,100 wrote the Aristocats - lost in New
York on fanfiction.net in this story
Murray finds herself in New York City
and she was totally lost she meets up
with Oliver and they fall in love but
then they get captured by Cruella De Vil
it's a triple crossover it's got love
and adventure and it's so cute Oliver
and Murray are made for each other
honestly we can't believe Disney didn't
think of it first check out this awesome
story for some great Disney vibes Tiana
and Dimitri the best thing about fan
fiction is the crossovers that don't
have to be in the same fandom and there
are some amazing ships between Disney
and non Disney characters this new
couple pairs Tiana from Princess and the
Frog and Dimitri from an estate
the 1990s princess cartoon Anastasia
honestly feels a lot like a Disney movie
so it's not that far of a leap
it takes place around the same time as
princess in the fog and we already know
Dimitri has a soft spot for princesses
our New Orleans with written by pure
Chacon it's a one-shot story on
fanfiction.net plus it has characters
from other Disney movies too it's an au
where Dimitri is brothers with Milo from
Atlantis and Jim from Treasure Planet
and this story is so romantic it's
written from Demetrius point of view he
meets Tiana when they are just kids and
it's so beautifully written then they
get older and things change it talks
about how time changes friendships and
about friends falling in love it even
touches a little on race relations in
New Orleans it's a little bittersweet at
times but it has a happy ending
this story totally made us fall in love
with the Tiana Dimitri ship Merida and
hiccup there are a few Disney non-disney
crossover couples which are more popular
than most and you can't talk about
crossover ships without talking about
America with How to Train Your Dragon 3
coming out it's the perfect time for
some hiccup fanfiction is this what you
want ok
and he is often paired with Merida from
brave Merida gets a lot of attention in
the fanfic world because she doesn't
have a cannon love-interest mara cop is
perfect
Vikings definitely made it to Scotland
in their travels so it makes sense that
they would meet Merida and hiccup are
both sort of Outsiders in their
communities at first Merida doesn't want
to get married she's too adventurous
hiccup isn't your traditional tough
Viking but what if hiccup is exactly the
man Merida needs she definitely wouldn't
be scared by dragons and she would help
pull hiccup out of his shell there are
so many greats Marek up stories that it
was hard to choose our favorite but we
loved The Brave and the bold it was
written by loquitur eos on
fanfiction.net in this story hiccup
competes for Merida's hand in marriage
at the competition from the beginning of
brave can hiccup win the heart of a
princess who doesn't want love it's both
funny and romantic and it feels so true
to the characters are you America
shipper keep watching to find out one of
the most popular Disney crossover
couples ever balanced Cinderella
we love princess ships and balance
Cinderella might be one of the best
femme / Disney ships these two are both
classic Disney Princesses fellas quiet
reserved and bookish she is brave and
would do anything for her father and she
really believed in true love Cinderella
does not deserve how she was treated by
her stepmother she was kind and quiet
and she made friends with mice just like
Belle she dreamed about a new life and
true love but what if their happily ever
after wasn't in the form of a prince
maybe they're meant for each other there
are a bunch of stories out there that
ship Belle and Cinderella summer from
the live-action movies and others are
from the cartoons but they are all
pretty great on fanfiction.net there is
a thick called who needs a prince it was
written by a zap the basic premise is
Belle finds out that Prince Adam is not
very faithful now that he's human again
Cinderella's relationship just kind of
fell apart after all they'd only shared
one dance before they fell in love and
got married but now she owns a
restaurant Belle stumbles onto the
restaurant Belle stays to help work
they're desperate for something new
we love cafe a
in fanfic and this one is great Alice
and Peter we love when we see fix about
underrated Disney characters Alice in
Wonderland is a Disney classic about a
girl who would prefer not to do boring
things like schoolwork she stumbles into
a magical world called Wonderland Peter
Pan is about a boy who never grows up in
the magical world of Neverland sounds
like a match made in heaven right both
characters are a little immature and
they both have friends in magical worlds
it's perfect
Alice in Wonderland and Peter Pan
crossovers are fairly common and they
often involve Alice falling down the
wrong rabbit hole into neverland but
this one is a little different
Alice and Peter Britain by Twilight
Sparkle three five six two on
fanfiction.net is very similar to the
original Peter Pan story Alice's family
tells her she must grow up but she
doesn't want to Peter comes and takes
her to Neverland but then there's a huge
twist the Queen of Hearts has teamed up
with Captain Hook to search for Alice
it's a drama an adventure story and a
romance all in one will Allison Peter
stay together in Neverland you'll have
to read it to find out mogera
and beast we have to include a rare pair
just for fun you may not think these two
characters belong together
but this benthic may just change a mind
you might remember mogera or Meg from
Hercules she's a sassy woman who is
pretty convinced she doesn't need love
with nice shootin rocks
looks like your games over Wonder Boy is
hitting every curve you throw Adam we
love her attitude and bravery
then there's beast he's a bit well
beastly he's not refined and he
definitely needs someone to put him in
his place and maybe locking a girl up as
a prisoner isn't the only way to meet
someone fanfiction has a lot of a use
that are really common like being
roommates cafes and schools and there is
a lot of Disney high school thick out
there this Megan B's story takes place
at an all Disney high school so you'll
get to see a lot of fun characters how
to be a heartbreaker part one was
written by Chiara Jade on fanfiction.net
in this story the Beast goes by his
human name Adam and all of their friends
ship them together but Meg isn't so sure
it's a really cute funny story and it's
totally made us fall in love with this
rare pair could you see Meg and the
Beast being a couple it would certainly
be interesting Elsa and Jack Frost when
it comes to Disney crossover couples
there is one that is more popular than
anything else
Elsa is a queen with some icy powers
she's shipped with lots of characters
because she doesn't have a love interest
in frozen Anna what do you know about
true love then there's Jack Frost's from
DreamWorks rise of the Guardians just
like Elsa he is able to manipulate ice
and snow Elsa is a fierce no-nonsense
woman Jack Frost is a total rebel their
personalities would definitely make for
an awesome hilarious relationship and if
they combined powers they could freeze
everything Elsa and Jack Frost are
totally made for each other there are so
many great stories with these two
characters but one of the best is on
archive with our own snowflakes fall and
snow - I was written by crazy animation
chick it's a great romance story we love
the way else is portrayed in this Vic
this story is also a crossover with How
to Train Your Dragon and brave and
Rapunzel and Moana make an appearance -
it's an animated masterpiece Elsa and
Jack Frost are such a cool couple get it
who is your Disney crossover OTP don't
be shy let us know in the comments those
are the 10 Disney crossover couples that
we love to ship in the fanfic world give
this video a big thumbs up and click
that subscribe button for more awesome
content
[Music]